duction sex comic so in this talk I will
talk about we'll continue this theme of
approximate company and in particular I
will focus on Tuesdays in systems so I
lack the last talk of all variables in
my pocket will be like a pooling at the
other one so I will not talk about
tonight color and stuff okay oh and this
is a including some bit of can't walk
with P&O and lastly on go back okay so
let's start so this is the easing model
which is a very classical model which
has been very well studied so for the
easy model we have these edge
interaction matrix beta 1 1 beta where
each number encodes the infection of the
states of the two endpoints of a edge so
we want so this is define the
distribution on the configurations where
each configuration is an assignment from
vs to equal 0 1 so each vertex is like a
variable pulling variable and the
interaction is given by this matrix so
if the two endpoints are so 400 it gives
beta 1 1 also gives pizza and 0 1 1 0
gives one this is the same as the
statistical physics easy model because
we just normalize all we do is normalize
the 01 interaction the different the
interaction when two verses are
different 2 1 and they are we denote the
other interaction as Peeta and the
weight of the configuration is like a
pita to the number of monochromatic
edges in the graph under this
computation and the the distribution
matter is proportional to this weight
and here is a concrete example we are
everywhere hexadecyl blue or 0 and each
edge gives a weight of pita and this
computer has a wheat waiter like a pita
to the eighth and also this is a
paragraph so it can give a configuration
such that we can smoke by color it and
every actor will convince a one because
every edge is different
so the weight is just the one and the
more generally we have some computation
have some weight and we are interested
in the particular function which is to
sum over all possible completions of
their own weight and the way it is a
bigger to the number of monochromatic
edges in this world okay and we will
talk about the complexity of
approximating this position function so
to recap this is a easy model which beta
1 beta into action and we have no field
on the vertices so that means we have
just wait one for the vertex so we
denote this fight with a cofactor 11 so
this will be our notation for the air
injection and the vertex whipped and we
will talk about a slightly more general
to stay spin system where we have three
parameters we have beta gamma and a
lambda so beta is the zero zero
interaction and gamma is like 11 and the
lambda is the weight of zero vs most of
that this matrix is still like symmetric
learnings dear 110 on the same so the
graph is still like undirected if we
make these two different than graph will
be directed which is not what I'm going
to talk about okay and again we are
interested in approximating this pattern
function Z of become lambda so compactly
will depend on the three parameters okay
so here are some examples some well
known systems such as easy model we have
seen in the first slide we get this
before 11 beta and this is no field case
so we have a null birdhouse field so get
Jeff get this weight and also this is so
called a gas model which we have seen
the master talk which is basically way
to the infant set now the interaction
matrix is 0 1 1 1 which means if the two
endpoints are posed as are in the zero
that is not allowed so zero sort of
enclosed occupied vertices and we have
bird has weight of lambda so each occupy
the vertex will contribute a weight of
lambda and the dependent function is sum
over all infinite sets of their own
weights and here with some other intern
sets because if it's not anything cept
than this ad in action will gives away
20 and so in this talk we are going to
talk about approximately counting the
reason is the exact evaluation of Z is
number be hard unless some trivial cases
I kept it at I'm comments 1 or potatoes
nom equal 0 lambda equal 0 for like the
negative parameters so for approximately
counting we will be talking about a
furious and Peeta's which you should
have seen in previous two talks that
Peters is just the deterministic version
of appearance and the recovery time is
polynomial in N 1 over epsilon and buy
some classical results by charm ballads
and Ronnie approximating the Palean
function is equivalent to to
approximately the marginal probabilities
in a suave due to some self reducibility
so later on when I talk about algorithms
I will just talk about how to
approximate the marginal probabilities
and before moving on to the results
there's one more distinguishing of these
systems which are called a ferromagnetic
or anti ferromagnetic so basically we
have this in a deduction pitiable on
gamma and if P the times gamma equals 1
that this system is actually trivial
because each edge can be decomposed into
two half a day's like two unary
functions so this is a trivial case and
more generally we have a ferromagnetic
of antiferromagnetic interaction for
example for easing that means pika
equals come a larger than one orbital
lab equals common lesson one when his
ferromagnetic different neighbors tend
to have you know typical configuration
different neighbors neighbors tend to
have the same spin because their weight
is like a larger than one if they are
equal so it's larger than the anti
diagonal and the anti-fur case is the
reverse neighbors tend to have a
different space and for the more general
case we will distinguish the depending
on whether be the times gamma is larger
than 1 or not okay so here is the
outline of this talk i will first first
part will be a survey on anti
ferromagnetic to spin systems there's a
great advance in recent years a week
more or less completely classified all
anti ferromagnetic to Smith systems that
will reporter some recently result i had
with a piano on ferromagnetic to spin
systems and if i have time i will move
on to talk about how about going beyond
like the non-negative numbers talk about
the complex with you the easy model this
is joint work with basically codebook
and in this case i will be talking about
approximation of the norm of the
potential function that is not clear how
to approximately complex number ok
so first let me briefly recap like what
do we know for antiviral systems the
upshot is that phantom power systems if
we have FPS for the pedigree function if
I normally for correlation decatur so
the notion of courage and decay so
that's what happened going to explain in
the next few slides so again let's take
the helical model as an example so this
is our task is now to approximately
accounting way to the Indian set for a
so you know only the degree graph this
problem is shown to have a awesome if
lambda is less than lambda C well um
says came by this quantity I just also
talked about this in the last talked and
if lambda is larger than on the sea is
actually at me hard and we don't really
know after the third house we know is we
can approximate to the log that in
function as it's at home but the
different itself we don't know if the
undersea is factor Amy how to even
approximate the lock and this algorithm
is due to wise in 2006 and the hardest
part is due to sly and also signed soon
and the Quran is step-uncle agenda
Dakota yeah so next I will explain
what's this lambda cities and this has
already explained it but I will help
explain it more from the offers in
wicker point of view so this is the
uniqueness our whole for gives matters
in even the regular trees which I to
naught by T Delta so we consider the
influence of the leaves to the root V
and we will consider some two extreme
cases when all the leaves are zero all
leaves are one so any other case will be
between these two extreme cases so let's
say it all leaves are zero because in
our encoding zero means occupied so
their marginal probability at the root
sorry at the leaf is one and we can see
this in turn set we know that the next
level
they must be not occupied so the modern
prophet is zero and we can continue this
sort of Shri recursion and until we get
the route we get some number p plus and
the in the other case all these are
occupied so we can delete them the next
iowa or free the amalfi know is like
lambda 1 plus lambda again we can
continue the psaltery recursion
computation will get some number p minus
the question is that these two numbers
goes to the same or not so it doesn't
leave me to exist for arbitrary boundary
conditions and it sends out the par-70
medical 0 if and only if lambda is less
i'm due to this lambda C so here is
another picture to try to explain what
happens for for this phenomena so here
is the three regular infantry and if
nonetheless now we go to the critical
value then in factor every vertex will
have the same marginal probability i say
p stop it will be some uniform for
overseas and if a number is larger than
lambda see that will have two different
extremal typical cases where in the one
case the even levels will all have a p+
and now all the level will all have a
few manners but the graph is like a
vertex transitive therefore we can swap
them we can get a p minus at the root
and even levels and if you pass at the
all levels so that means after the leaf
they they are sort of a people's of
emails will influence the root being
people p minus even if the distance is a
very very long so so the boundary have a
non-negligible influence on the route
they will not be larger than our see ok
so so this sort of uniqueness can be
formalized as and so called a week
spatial mixing
which said that for two different
configurations two different boundary
conditions they are the difference of
the margin life of the root is
exponentially small in terms of the
distance from V to the configuration so
this is called week special mixing this
is actually equivalent to the uniqueness
if we ignore the decay rate part of the
exponential part and what turns out to
be useful is another notion called
strong spatial mixing now for isms it is
that instead of measuring the distance
from V to the boundary we measure the
distance from V to where the two
configurations differ so in other words
we kind of allow some branch to
terminate early we can allow some
paintings before the place we want to
sort of cut off and and those paintings
will be the same for Sigma and tau and
we don't matter the distance in terms of
those so translate this is a stronger
because we might as well has no set of
paintings so transmission mixing implies
a week and the week is equivalent to you
Nick nice but why this idea this notion
is important is that what shoulder if we
have strong spatial mixing in infinite
regular trees then we have our Peters
for in graphs of a degree less than
equal dealt so this is kind of a
sufficient condition for the existence
of a pitas so what's idea is basically
the following we kind of want to mimic
as a tree recursion we want to use the
tree recursion to calculate the modern
probabilities in general rafts so what
we do is we try to break the cycles and
so came over has v of lactic righty the
first thing we do is we replace it by
like T many copies then notice that the
ratio between the manager probabilities
is equal to the ratio between all the
copies being zero and all the coffee's
being one the next we can rewrite it as
a telescoping product of this form and
the each of the term term viewed as a
marginal probability ratio of some VI
for example this one will correspond to
be three and the v1 v2 and v4 in this
branch will be pinged according to the
zero zero and ones so in other words we
kind of created a d-minus instances of
the original graph but with Seoul s vs
and with some boundary conditions to
calculate the marginal of the original
of the marginal of sort of the ratio in
the original graph so this leads to the
construction of the so-called
self-evolving work trees this type of
all emotion is essentially the tree of
separating works plus vs. that close the
cycles so in this construction if we
pick a particular branch biases as if we
walk towards that and these boundary
conditions will not come into play
unless we finish the cycle so that's why
we want to include those cycles the
verses that close cycles and it should
be fixed according to this rule like a
for the branch include a corresponding
to v3 than v1 v2 if we met them in the
future that they should be paying 20 and
before three things one if we met it we
very likely will not see it in the
future actually so to doing this week
from a graph tree like this we will get
some trees that say we look at the
perhaps V so we get a tree starting of
supporting walks starting from a and
here like we have work a to b then we
have a to b and we have a CDA which is a
cycle so we get a CT
and a and not a is pinned according to
these rules and now we can calculate the
marginal probability in this tree
instead of in the original graph tree is
easy because we always do the recurrence
of dynamic programming from bottom up
but there's a question is the problem of
this construction that this cell phone
work shape will be exponential size
because otherwise we would solve a
number of people problem in polynomial
time so this is exponential sighs so
watch the idea is to truncate this tree
trunk in this recursion with in
polynomial time so that means within
sort of a logarithmic a depth now now
add to the boundary everywhere we
truncate we don't really know what the
true value should be so we're just plug
in some arbitrary values now the
question is how large is the arrow and
this condition of so-called strong
special mixing bonds this error so here
is the our original tree and we sort of
truncated at the fifth level on these
two verses enf so their true value
should depend on what's below them but
are we truncated so we don't know we
just planning some random battles here
and this strong spatial mixing condition
guarantee is that whatever the true
value is the influence after the root is
very very small it decays exponentially
in terms of the the tabs under this
strong spit the strong part in this
transmission mixing real is really
useful because we need to deal with
these early paintings that happens
before this level and alternatively if
we have no names unique this for example
we just have a tree regular tree then if
it's not unique then of course we have a
constant error in this scheme because
when we truncate we really need to know
that what the true value is to recover
the margin actually route ok so this is
how wise hours and goes and so now we
know that if we speed on the uniqueness
then the size and the address at all and
the side soon results show that the only
naked is hard and the wise results show
that before strong special mixing we
have autism but the concern is whether
these two are the same and this is
established for all and the Pharaohs to
Smith systems by sinclair shifts around
30 and also lead one in in several
papers so this is true and therefore for
antiviral to smith systems the
uniqueness is equivalent to strong
spatial mixing which in turn is
equivalent to the distance of arpita's
and now you may notice that this
uniqueness is defined for pounding the
degree graphs or like a infinite regular
trees of a certain degree so for general
graphs we require uniqueness hold for
all integer degrees so this will not be
true for like say Indian set because the
circle of Indian settle because 0 if you
t goes to infinity and also for like a
easy model it is also will not hold for
Telegraph's but their uses some bit
hangama so that is really true and what
happened there is that the this fair
hold is not not monotone so there exists
a peak and if our field is larger than
the peak then the link is hold for any
degrees so for again for for antivirus
system we have this perfectly
correspondence among unique nice strong
special mixing and a penis now the
question is colleagues generalized that
two ferromagnetic spin systems and the
unfortunately it does seem to be the
case so one typical example is the
ferromagnetic easing model again this is
easy so we have been a larger than one
we have this pika one won't be higher
interaction and we have no field I say
this is very well studied we
understood the wells to the face
foundation in even regular fries long
ago there you see say a critical Peter
see which is evocative over the
optimality and when that goes infinity
this just goes to 1 and therefore
there's no Peter such that this house
for all the inter degrees however we
have the awesome do to german singer
that even for general graphs not
necessarily bound a degree we always
have a fear us that is based on markov
chains foot so we do have autism even if
the unique is failed so then the
question is like so what would hate the
truth ik what is should be the criteria
for this case the interesting thing
about them terms in catching that it
works in the subgraph world instead of
the original easing word and it is shown
to be fast mixing for any easing model
and even so if the fields are sort of
consistent so suppose we have like a
non-uniform fill the lambda v four
different vs and if they are all rather
than one are all less than 1 then this
change is fast mixing and even if the
uniquely sauce transforming phil's so
this is extended to general being a
gamma case let's assume Peter that's on
you to come up because they are really
symmetric this circle the one is
generalized to like a Peter come over
Peter so the first time x 2 square root
of this bike over charm person and the
data to come over be high baidee LuAnn
the trunk so what really happens here
that a sync speed has vessel comma so
Eddie's will favor gum and this ratio
come over beta will be rather than one
therefore versus the favors by Peter so
mercy then Edie's favorite different
spins therefore there is certain tension
among them and
question is so the criteria is like if
the tension is not so strong then we can
have awesome if it is too strong than
dogs moved fit and the ether versity vs
and that is post favors all of the same
spin that's a betta than the problem
easy is it due to the German secret over
here is a picture for Pharaoh to swing
systems we have a big hello on gamma and
we have some 90 min to 450 lambda V so
for general graphs so this is a awesome
based on charm Sinclair Chang due to
Luna John we have this fair hold of calm
over theta and in the same paper they
also show that the problem becomes peace
heart if it's laminated louder than
certain quantity which I column the sea
int so here peace hobbies like the
optimal result because all the problems
in feral what is this easy so this is
really like beasts equivalent you can't
get anything harder than peace so this
quantity lambda C int is defined by this
come over beta to a certain power which
is Delta C to the floor the other c plus
1 over G as in the indicates this I call
it a run the sea ink because that I have
another quantity lambda C which is just
coming over to the LZ over to notice
that if kelsey is very very close for
integer then this country and this
county are very very close but if it is
an integer it's actually differ by 1 so
what we showed is that for all of the
less than this lambda see a certain kind
of special mixing hold which I call
conditional special mixing and I will
explain in the next slide and this is
sort of a weaker version of strands
visual mixing and it doesn't require to
imply an autism but it does for a
special case when peter is less than the
one last thing to come so in being a
lesson
one exactly the verse the ad is strongly
not favoring beta our conditional
special mixing actually implies a fetus
but if you behave rather than one it
doesn't have any others in wicker
implication now so this is some John
work with the piano so what do I mean by
this conditional special mixing it is
that follows so in some sense the strong
special mixing is together against the
worst case pinnings in the south or
deviltry so instead of that we only
allow sort of accrued paintings we only
allow boundary conditions that are
dominated by like isolated vertices so
that means the margin of the boundary
condition is less likely to the lambda 1
plus lambda or intuitive way overseas
are leaning towards the social good
space and we show that this with this
the painting safe I this than these
conditional special mixing holds for any
tree the without any funky degree and it
is not it also not necessarily regular
so this is a picture of a strong special
mixing we have this supporting work tree
and we kind of truncated at certain
level and we want to compare the
influence of all blue versus all red in
this tree but this does not satisfy our
conditional special mixing because we
have these rare paintings rather kind of
the bad painting let's say so instead we
are asking suppose this thinning the all
blue and does he DK and I'm over we
cannot allow like we can also compare
our blue to all red instead we have all
sort of a blue or white and here we
allow proofing in there we can allow up
to sort of a white hitting but not for
anything red and we show that if these
are satisfied than all blew over
or white is kind of a decays influence
decays exponentially in the distance if
you look at the all blow over all red
exactly not sure this decay okay but
this is not what happened in a sample
avoiding work tree why does our special
mixing implies any officer that is
because there is sort of a strongly
unfavored PETA therefore keeping a cell
for welding walk free originally is like
this we can remove those rare paintings
and the effectively with his what is
removing does is it gives a field on the
Anglia parents and as a picture
indicates when I only remove those when
Peter is less time with one do the
parent will actually favored blue it
will not be as strong as the blue but it
will be some less blue but still blue is
not red that's a point so and also for
the boundary condition we know that the
town via the sort of the marginal is
also not read and it's like terminated
by a white so we can simply compare all
blue with all white so in other case so
in essence in other words we establish
that in this case the condition of
special mixing implies strong special
mixing so this is enough for autism so
what happened when pete has rather than
one again we can still do this pruning
stuff but there's a problem that after
we remove these rare paintings there
apparently is still leaning towards
ready it's like less red but it's too
red so our our condition doesn't really
hold for these strong spirit as for
these self avoiding work trees but we do
have a observation that if a lambda
these lessons is created for lambda c
than the marginal probability for any
graph any vertex is actually less than
equal to lambda 1 pesamal so in some
sense for any graph if we do have any
perhaps they are always in this
condition holds they are always leaning
towards the good spin but it's just that
when we do the supporting worked
reconstruction we need to do this
telescoping product and we will
artificially create a lot of red
paintings which caused a problem so
these of open question is that can we
get a fetus without this strong spatial
mixing condition and indeed a week we
have some results so the sum John work
with basic / stephane college Carolinas
and cobalt we have some pitas with all
strands which mixing for like hyper
graph in pencil problem but it's not
clear how to apply those techniques in
this setting so I think this is kind of
the major open problem for this for this
problem for this model okay and the oath
before I go to that
yeah it's more so another question is
what is the exact air hose remember we
have this long ass emmc int they are
differ by a very small cap however we
notice that the needs of these are the
red bond so none of them is tight there
is some small interval PLM see where the
epi does still exist that is because
integrate has to be integers so remember
in the lambda see we have some Delta Z
stuff which is known as integer that
kind of works as the degree for our
algorithm but the degrees has to be
integers so we can actually show the
exists more info beyond that the exist
still use this algorithm and also for
them the less than this lumba st. we
actually can construct an example such
as a strong special mixing fails so in
other words it says that if the
non-negative so if the uniqueness for
evening regular trade holds for what
integer tigre delta we still don't have
a strong special mixing so this is very
different from the anti-fur case this is
even if like a beta less than you 21 so
this construction is actually irregular
she so let's say the LC is 6 so soft was
degraded 6 the instead of a six regular
tree we construct a irregular tree with
degrees five and seven and five and
seven and so on like a some alternating
degrees then we observe that is the
correlation decay in such a regulatory
is worse than the infinite regular trees
on so in a different case we can view
even regular trees as the worst case
scenario but in the in the federal case
is not true anymore even even if Peter
lesson 1 which is sort of either case so
the question is where is the tied to our
health between these two so we kind of
observe either of those are tied
and advice I will talk about a complex
easy model so everything is the same as
before we have the easy model people on
beta we have no field so we want to
compute this quantity there's only
twisting that have not been her maybe a
complex number and again the exact
evaluation is well understood let's do
to some real of a long time ago I really
vertical in the wash so this is number 3
hot and I some salt fever cases will be
80 plasmids well past my son so this is
becomes interesting for us it's due to
some cavalry recent results by free
jenna mourey may so they show that the
exist upon term circulated called the IQ
p such that if you can value to this
korean function at the root of unity
then you can simulate those quantum
circuits you value to the norm of the
parent function at the root of unity
Thank assimilated the quantum circuit
and the continuing to draw conclusions
about these using some more quantum
mechanics but thats begs the question
like what really is the complexity of
approximating these norms without using
any quantum like can we see something
use sort of a classical techniques so
here's the picture here's a
approximation come back to offer this
norm of the petition and in fact that we
allow we are not very strict if the if
the parent function is 0 so you may kind
of expect the honeys comes from zeros of
the function if you beat a like complex
number but we kind of a law arbitrary
output if this is really easy row so
even for the relaxed version what i'm
going to talk about is still true so
here is a complex plane and first we
have these tractable result due to a
long time ago we have these five points
0 and the plus minus 1 plasma is I are
tractable and the champ Sinclair chain
told us is
we have a puras if bi is louder than one
and in the same paper the show that the
problem is np-hard if bi is between zero
and the late along cobalion jerem show
that if we are less than zero by the
vaginal minus one the problem is still
and be hard and if we are less than
minus 1 then the problem actually is
equivalent to accounting perfect
matchings approximately accounting
perfect matchings in general rafts this
is still a open question we have the the
Epirus for private holographs for
counting perfect matchings in paragraphs
but we don't know the general compact
see approximation complexity so this is
what happens in the video is real and
the first thing we show is that other
than these real axis other than these 2
trackball points everything else is in
the art honors so it's sort of our first
result it kind of completes the picture
except they're not quite because when
theta is between 0 and minus 1 it's
actually number be hard to approximate
this null so if the if the pointing
wrong compute is like a within are
within number p that we can use and the
Oracle to approximated but here these
these quantities are not necessarily in
number P because they have negative
numbers or complex numbers so two
approximates coffee is actually number
we have so we strengthen these honeys
result of any honeys to not be Amish and
this used the idea that is employed
earlier by Goldberg and jarom about
determining the son of the tub
polynomial so basically given Oracle of
approximating the norm of this paneer
function that we can do a bisection
argument to recover the answer to some
number p hard problem ok so based on
this we have reduced with reductions to
other points for example for the points
of interest of the communities and more
generally any
that has normal one on this unit circle
the circle they are all non-free hard
and from that we can show that
everything on the imaginary excesses
that really hard and foremost upon like
actually half of the pawns it's like a
number he hard apparently I cannot draw
a point of this sauce it got you to
cover the whole plane we conduct her
actually every point that should never
be hard but I already can't quite show
that we show the many points at ha oh
this is counting perfect matchings this
is like a still open question with we
have autism to count approximately count
for matchings in paragraphs that's the
charm supplier the gold algorithm but it
doesn't generalize the arbitrary graphs
if it's not perfect counting by
four-time independent set it's not peace
it's not this it's like a different open
problem yeah it is like poster open but
we don't know their relationship like it
maybe they are equal we don't know maybe
they're both hot so this is pretty much
the picture and I guess I don't really
have time to talk about the proof so if
we go through this so basically this is
what i said i was once relaxed version
and which news from this the problem
called minimum kinetic SD card which is
shortly never be harder for programmable
and we use this son how nice technique
and there's a reduction is that we sort
of rewrite the participating function as
a linear functional in some variable X
so that we can tweak and then we can do
some bisexual argument given the norm of
the appended functions and we can
conclude okay final we r 0 is and using
the zero we can find out the quantum
well compute
and we also have some further result of
comparison with field here we only
consider case it will be a gambit and
lambda a disability because this is how
the interest in case for quantum
communication and also we have some
result for like approximating the
argument the angle of the Palean
function so this is again related to
quantum due to some result I Povich
freedom and love arts and Welsh so the
answer this question for telephone room
you at some point on planar graphs we
show this number be hard for general
graphs so it's kind of an indication
that this should be hard but we don't
cry to show that okay so that's about it
let's finish with some open questions so
for any peril to swing system the major
of them question is what about the
approximation come back to the adverts
are health we know that the correlation
does decay but it decays not with
exponential rate we together with some
polynomial rate so the only gives us a
approximation for dog partition rather
than padding function itself and the
four Pharaohs systems the question is
what happens when people other than one
do we have a fitness when these
contingent host we can't actually there
should be one we don't know that's
ambitious question is can we show this
conditional special mixing for graphs in
style of trees so when we show is trees
for graphs the intuitively you can pick
a spanning tree and you a daddy's and
because it is a favor of gamma when i
whenever you add that is is should make
the decay stronger and stronger but it's
very hard to form like this intuition
the interior is should be true but we
don't know how to prove it
also another compassion is how to avoid
the gap in the honey's proof so what I
showed earlier is 49 uniform field if we
want to show how these four uniform
field we need to construct get it then
carries are also combinatorial there
will be an integrated gap again so how
to avoid their cap seems to be a
difficult question we can do the random
regular paragraph construction as in a
dress talked about in the last hug but
the problem is we have we will have two
faces but to the one face will dominate
the other so we can't use that for the
harvest proof so this is another
question another open question how to
avoid this schedule gap ok that's it
Thank You speaker